so so many of us have these wonderful
ideas and oh wow that's so funny you
should put that line in a movie
but you just said to us off camera which
sparked this great question
that sometimes it's a gentle nudge when
something is
really great for a script and sometimes
it's not yeah
you know i think part of the trick is
knowing when the idea has entered your
brain
and rather than just thinking oh well
that's a funny situation that that
happened or that's an interesting
situation and not connecting it to
hey wait a minute i can write about that
i um
i wrote a play about my parents and my
parents toxic marriage and divorce and a
fairly dark time in my life and the um
play uh was going to have two stage
readings at the pasadena playhouse with
a well-known actress
playing my mother at the reading and i
was very excited about this
and i hadn't talked to my mother in many
years at that point in time
and i was walking around really in a
sunny mood about wow this great actress
is going to be reading my
words in my play in front of an audience
and i was so excited and then i had this
waking nightmare that my mother was
going to show up
at the reading and jump up on stage and
say that's not true
that's a lie you have to hear my side of
the story and
i just sort of laughed at myself for
being paranoid but then it occurred to
me i went hey wait a minute that's a
good idea for a play
someone who's been writing about their
family and their family descends upon
them
and it's not a fully formed idea you
have to then do your work as a writer
and
say okay so who are these people why
haven't they talked to each other
what happens when the person comes up on
stage how does the situation get
more complex that more complicated or
funnier or
any of those things who are the other
people involved all of that work
that's the the job of being a writer of
taking
a germ of an idea and trying to grow it
into a full-blown
piece whatever that piece is if it's a
web series or or a play
but i think you have to develop the
skill of being tuned in
to your thoughts and feelings the world
around you when you're watching other
people in order to
know when an idea presents itself the
idea doesn't always say
hello i'm giving you an idea for a story
now that's part of being a writer
recognizing when the idea has presented
itself
or something as just hilarious as the
soup nazi just hits you over the head
yes that's funny but
do we can can we really base an entire
show off of it
and a long-standing character right yeah
i think knowing the difference between
an idea that can sustain a sketch and an
idea that can sustain a two-hour movie
or a character that's good for a couple
of scenes in a couple of episodes versus
a character that you can base a series
around
i think those are all judgment calls
that you have to make as a
as a writer and as a series creator that
you know
as funny as the soup nazi was on
seinfeld and i adore the super nazi
character
i would not want to do the soup nazi
series and there's a reason why they
have not done the soup nazi series
because it's the same joke over and over
again you know no soup two weeks for you
and you can't build a series around that
you need more complexity
you see this a lot of time when they try
and take sketches that have been very
funny on saturday night live and turn
them into feature films
and you just say this was a very bad
idea
and even with you know really good
material not all material
is as good in one form as it is in
another form you've seen plays that have
been
fantastic plays turned into it didn't
quite work movies and things like that
so and then there are pieces of material
that work across all kinds of
genres the odd couple's success as a
stage play a success as a feature film a
success as a television series so
and and i think they're actually trying
it again as we speak that matthew
perry's
doing a new version of the odd couple of
pilot this season
well what are some of the tips then
because it sounds like it's intuition
that's really guiding someone
or or are there some things you can work
out on paper
well i i think there are certain
guidelines that you have to
you need some experience to say is this
does this character have depth or is
this character one-dimensional
if the character's one-dimensional which
is the soup nazi
you know we and that's why we've only
seen him in that that
one dimension he's at the soup place and
and other people are interacting with
them
you can't build a series around it i do
think it takes some experience
and again i think it takes some um
missteps sometimes as a writer that you
think oh this is a great idea
and you write it and realize yeah this
is there's not enough to this idea yet
or i haven't developed this idea
enough to get a full series out of this
idea that said some of the experience my
students
at chapman have when um i teach the
webisode class there
they each write a pilot for a three to
five minute uh
web series pilot i pick two we shoot the
pilots
edit them and then make in the second
semester
right shooting at three more episodes of
each show and
sometimes there's great enthusiasm for
what seemed the funniest script and we
go and we shoot that
and then there just don't seem to be
enough episodes
ideas that come out of it and so by the
third or fourth episode
we're really struggling trying to come
up with an idea
you